hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our daily homeroom
live stream which is really just a way
of having interesting conversations and
staying connected during this time of
school closures and social distancing uh
before we get into what i expect to be a
very exciting and interesting
conversation with our guest i will give
my standard announcement we are a
not-for-profit and we're only able to
exist because of philanthropic donations
i want to give a special shout out to
several corporations that have stepped
up in the last few weeks especially as
our costs have gone up our usage has
been about 2.5 3x of what it typically
is during his covet crisis you can
imagine server costs and we're trying to
increase our programs uh and content for
a lot of folks so special thanks to bank
of america google.org novartis at t and
fastly and our many other supporters
who've been supporting khan academy
through the years that have really put
us in a position to be able to do the
work we're doing now we still are
running at a deficit so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
making a donation to khan academy
with that out of the way i'm excited to
introduce our guest today david leonhart
who's a writer for the new york times uh
good to see you david
good to see you sal thanks for having me
no it's an honor and you know you've
been writing for a little while and and
you're you're doing a lot this summer or
the spring on inequality so
what got you interested in inequality
um i i guess uh i mean my my background
when i was in school was my favorite
subject was math um uh and but i also
really liked working on this the student
newspaper so i think to some extent it's
just a reflective of this long time
interest that i've always had of
describing the world around me using
numbers and then doing it for a general
audience rather than an academic
audience
but i but then as i became a journalist
over the last 25 years
i really came to think this was
one of the most important things really
along with climate change going on in
our country the fact that um the living
standards of most americans don't track
anymore with the statistics you read on
what our economy as a whole is doing and
that really creates all kinds of
problems and
in a way that's really what inequality
is
and so i think it affects everything
from politics to obviously living
standards to education to health we
clearly see playing out now in the
coronavirus and so it's one of these
things in which everywhere i looked
around or almost everywhere i saw
inequality kind of um as an explanation
for a lot of the huge trends in in our
society
and i want to look at some of the charts
in a little bit from some of your op-ed
pieces and some of your articles you've
written but
you know just as a maybe this would be a
naive question but just as a level set
you know in in society some level of
inequality one would might argue is
inevitable
why is is there a certain threshold of
when inequality becomes too much is is
is what and you said they could lead to
problems what type of problems do you
think
in you know
large inequalities could lead to
yeah i think that's an important level
set um i mean i think
not only is some degree of inequality
probably inevitable but i would go so
far as to say it's probably desirable
the the societies that have tried to get
rid of inequality entirely have failed
essentially um and probably the the best
most tangible modern example is in china
in which um in the 1970s china
discovered that it was really having a
hard time getting anything done um
because they were insisting that
everyone was gonna have the same no
matter what people weren't farming their
lands in efficient ways um uh and the
the great sort of economic revolution in
china was led by deng xiaoping in which
he tried to move essentially toward a
system that was going to inevitably
result in more inequality but it also
lifted almost everyone's
living standards the problem is when
inequality just gets too too big and
we've seen this happen a number of times
throughout history it happened in in
parts of the late 19th century in this
country it happened in the 1920s and
when inequality gets too big you have
many problems but i'll highlight two
one is that the people who are amassing
huge amounts of society's resources end
up being able to essentially set the
rules through the amount of influence
they have over both the economy and
politics to make sure they never lose
what they have and two is you end up
with a lot of people whose living
standards just aren't rising very
rapidly um because you have such a large
share of society's resources going to
such a small portion of society and you
know it's subjective about when it's too
much
but when you look at just how much
inequality has increased over the last
30 40 50 years in the society it's been
so extreme that i think you either have
to say well boy something was terribly
wrong in our society in the 50s and 60s
and it was too equal or something is
wrong now and it's too unequal it's hard
to really imagine that that both um can
work well
and and there's this fairness argument
which you make very well just now that
you know at some point you know money to
some degree is power and then that power
could be to
keep more money or and then obviously
there's a fairness that it just gets at
some point unfair but are there other
implications i mean are if it gets too
unequal or you know things like the
french revolution or i mean it does just
the nature of our democracy become less
stable
uh i think it does um there there's a
fascinating book by a couple of
political scientists um in which they
look at um why nations fail i believe
that's actually the title of the book um
and they argue that over the course of
history inequality is
the key not the only but is the key
reason why societies decline that when
basically you have societies in which
the mass of people are not enjoying
rising living standards it can lead to
political instability it could it also
can end up being a real waste of talent
if large sections of your society are
closed off from opportunity or even if
they're not completely closed off if
opportunity is so difficult then most of
the people in those sections of society
will not be allowed to escape it you end
up missing out on huge amounts of talent
there's a recent research paper called
lost einsteins that tries to quantify
some of the cost of our rise in
inequality and the idea is that there
are probably
hundreds of kids today who might reach
the very very top of science and other
fields if only they
had better opportunities than they do
and so um there really are even if you
can't predict when those when those
bills will come due
um or exactly how they'll come due there
really are long-term costs and i think
even people who are on the happy end of
many of the inequality trends should
have some reason to worry that in the
long term it could lead to a society
that functions much less healthfully
than one where
living standards are rising broadly for
most of the population
and unless let's make that a little bit
more tangible if we could bring up that
first chart which is which comes from
one of david's articles
uh that shows inequality or actually it
shows per capita gdp over the last
several decades uh and how the different
groups and
david could you just explain what's
going on here it might be a little bit
small depending on how how large
people's screens are but what do we see
here
yeah so um i love this chart uh um and
so i think the place to start is exactly
where you said we should start which is
per capita gdp so that's that dark black
line um with per capita gdp pointing at
it um so that's basically over since
1980 that's the cumulative percentage
change in how much our economy produces
every year so you take the the total
value of everything we produce all the
services all the goods everything um
and then you divide it by the number of
people that's per capita um and you say
essentially if we divided our gdp
perfectly perfectly evenly which again i
don't recommend um that's uh what would
that's what would be happening and and
so you can see it's it's really rising
quite nicely in some ways right i mean
it's nearly 100 an increase of 100
so i'm sure most of the listeners know
would be a doubling okay so it hasn't
quite doubled since 1980 this is
adjusted for inflation but it's um but
it's come pretty close to doubling but
then you kind of get under that and you
look at what's happened to each economic
group and you look at at the bottom 50
well their incomes have risen they're
they're making more money than they were
in 1980 but they haven't risen that much
um and to be clear this is all an
inflation adjusted so it's not just you
know some people say oh things were
cheaper in 1950 but this is adjusted for
arguably for inflation this is real
income
this is adjusted for inflation and there
are fights about exactly how to do it
and is it perfectly done or is it
overstated or understated um and and
those are good interesting fights but
the bottom line is if you adjust for
inflation um you what you're really
trying to capture is the experience of
people's lives the fact that today
something you know what's a big mac
today five bucks the fact that it you
know it might have cost two bucks in the
past um i hope i'm not wrong about that
i don't need a lot of big macs um uh
that doesn't actually
show any significant difference between
it over time so you adjust for that um
so what you see here is that for the
bottom 50 or the middle 40 percent um
things have risen we're not you know
when people say that the middle class
today is making less money than it did
in the past um i think that's wrong
if you're looking at the long-term past
but the increases have been modest and
here i think is an important thing they
have been much smaller than the
increases you would expect based on what
our economy has been producing
you then move up to to what for
shorthand i call the upper middle class
the 90th and 99th percentile you've got
a lot of doctors in there you've got
lawyers you've got university professors
you've got a lot of professionals right
their income has tracked actually quite
closely with per capita gdp not
everyone's but as a group
and then when you get to the top one
percent and really to the the top of the
top one percent the top 0.01
you see that they're on a completely
different uh trajectory
their incomes are are tripling or
quintupling um and so when you see this
i think it helps you realize some of the
frustrations that people have um people
feel like wait a second even if i make
more money
than my grandparents did than my parents
did which some people do and some people
don't um it sure doesn't feel like i'm
keeping up with society as a whole and
they're right about that and it's not
just absolute changes that people judge
their lives on there's a rich
psychological research that shows its
relative changes as well i mean put it
this way sal if you and i worked at a
company where profits doubled and you
and i got a 10 raise the previous year
and we were and we could look and see a
bunch of other workers who got their
their pay tripled would we say oh my
goodness we're so happy we got a 10
raise or would we would say wait a
second this doesn't feel totally fair
and i think that's how a lot of
americans feel and their right to feel
that way
and before we get into potential causes
of these trends i will ask you know i'll
play devil's advocate a little bit which
is you know there's this argument look
we have market forces capitalism
it as you mentioned you don't want
absolutely equal you want motive you
know people to want to invest and take
risk and that might lead to some and
there's bad luck good luck that leads to
some level of inequality some would
argue that hey look
at the end of the day it looks like
everyone has improved in real terms why
should we be so caught up with the
relative wouldn't you rather have a
world where everyone is improving maybe
maybe some more than others than a world
where it's equal but we're not improving
as much
well sure i would i and i think that
part of the answer that question is
there this is definitely better than
some alternatives you could imagine it's
better than a world in which gdp wasn't
rising at all it's better than a world
in which only a small percentage of
people are seeing an increase and no one
else is seeing any kind of increase
but when you look across the relative
comparisons it seems to me it really
requires a stretch to argue that this is
the natural outcome so one relative
comparison would be other high-income
countries over the same period they've
also seen inequality rise but they
haven't seen it rise as much as the
united states has so some other
countries have figured out ways to have
middle class pay rise more rapidly and
and pay for low-income workers rise more
rapidly
than our pay has risen
maybe even more starkly those countries
have also had health and life expectancy
grow substantially more than the united
states has so it seems like they're
doing something differently from us and
and for much of the population
most of the population it's working
better
then you look at our own country between
the 1940s and the 1970s
by no means a perfect period the period
in which opportunities for women were
highly constrained
in which there was vicious often legally
sanctioned racism
in which large numbers of americans
couldn't vote
again by no means a perfect period but
when you look at these same measures
what you see is that the pay of nearly
every group if we look at this from the
40s to the 80s 40s to the 70s the pay of
every group would be much closer to that
black line and not only that but the pay
of the middle would actually have
increased a little bit faster than the
pay at the top
and so i
i don't i i think the burden the people
who say this is the natural outcome i
think actually the burden is on them to
explain well wait a second why is this
the natural outcome if it's not what the
united states used to have and it's not
what many other countries have had
and so given that let's go into possible
reasons for why this either is happening
around the globe which it sounds like it
has been happening to some degree and
especially uh in the case of the united
states what what what do you think are
the
are the the culprits here
so i think there are a few um and i
think they're all fascinating so i i
apologize i'll be going through them
extremely quickly if you want to dive
more into any one of them i think it's
clear that globalization is part of the
cause here and there's a lot that's
wonderful about globalization i mean for
for much of the late 20th century you
had large parts of the world that
essentially weren't competing in the
global economy either they were too poor
um or uh they were part of soviet uh the
soviet empire and essentially weren't
able to compete in the economy and so or
they were um europe or japan which was
essentially destroyed by world war ii
both of which so so um some of it is
this entrance of billions of people into
the global economy which has increased
competition particularly um for certain
kinds of labor and has and has created
problems for people in in the more
affluent world
um that's also wrapped up with
technological change which plays a role
there um then though i think there are a
set of forces that we have essentially
chosen um and just just to make sure we
all make sure i understand those points
about globalization and technology
because i think they're similar you know
someone say okay there's there's
competition around the world uh but why
is that disproportionately affecting the
lower incomes and your argument would be
technology and globalization you know
technology obviously now arguably a
robot or computer might be able to do
parts of that job and so it kind of
lowers the importance maybe of labor or
the at least the negotiating capability
and obviously if there's someone in
another country who could do that same
job and because of you know barrier
trade barriers have gone down and and
and monetary barriers have gone down
people can relocate factories and so now
so that could put
pressure on wages in in the us or in
richer countries if someone in another
country can do it for cheaper that's
precisely right i mean you take a
furniture manufacturer in north carolina
um has managed to move to latin america
or to asia
where workers to do um some of the same
work or maybe not as efficiently but if
they're being paid one-fifth as much
it doesn't matter if they're not quite
as efficient in doing it we've seen this
again and again if if workers are being
replaced by um foreign workers they
might be replaced being replaced by a
machine that can do what they they would
do and so maybe you used to have 10
workers doing something um manually or
with a factory uh assembly line now you
have two or three workers operating
computers um that make the same goods um
so those are true forces
really and just to be clear on
globalization the academic argument for
globalization is it actually makes the
pie larger and so you know the consumers
of those services or those goods might
be able to get for cheaper now and uh
also what's probably happening to your
point is those who own the technology or
have the capital they might be getting
better returns now because some of their
costs have gone up they're able to lower
the price so the consumers benefit but
then they're able to get better profit
because
their costs have gone down even more
yeah and then and i would argue maybe
even even bigger than either of those is
that um it can bring good jobs to people
around the world i mean you know the
last 50 years have seen the greatest
reduction in global poverty in recorded
history um it hasn't been in this
country it hasn't been in europe it
hasn't been in japan um but it has been
in china in india and large parts of
africa and south america and um
uh and so uh that is a very good
development for for for people who live
there it's very good
and that's a good disclaimer and we're i
can't wait to get all of the questions
we're getting but i do want to go
through all of the levers but this is
you know as we talk about these levers
even though a lever may be contributing
in some way to inequality we're not
saying a story that it's bad there might
be other positive aspects about it there
might be ways to mitigate those things
so i think very quickly you know people
say well i like globalization i don't
like globalization but it's like no well
there's just some things that it might
be contributing might have benefits
might have negatives same thing about
same thing about uh technology so let's
keep going through these levers then
i'll open it up to some of these
questions i'm seeing that's great i'm
excited to hear them so i mean i think
then there are a set of things where i
would argue that they are
in many ways policy choices that we have
made with either knowing that we're
making them or not necessarily knowing
so
one of the the really key changes is
that we are no longer
[Music]
producing educated um people increasing
the stock of educated people at the rate
that we used to be there's a fantastic
book by claudia golden and larry katz
called the race between education and
technology and the title captures a lot
of this which is the example i just gave
where you went from 10 workers to two
workers those two workers need to have
higher skills in order to operate
computers and if you think of the long
sweep of history you can kind of imagine
this race between education and
technology the technology gets more
sophisticated are we producing the kind
of workers who can use the new
technologies and there's been a huge
slowdown in educational attainment in
this country
even though
all the signs are that education pays
off and i know people say wait is
college overrated
but as i like to point out the people
who say is college overrated are often
making sure that their own kids are
going to college so i think in terms of
their own behavior people understand
that education is not overrated the
unemployment rate for college graduates
is vastly lower than for non-college
graduates the pay gap is is near an
all-time record college graduates live
longer
they are more likely to be happy they're
more likely to be healthy um and so but
we haven't done a good enough job
allowing more people to go to college
and and really to complete college so
education is one issue um
there's a good question on that i know
there's so many i hope we have a little
bit more time because i'm going to i
want to get through all these but
there's a question that's related to
your point about the college education
which i think is interesting mamata but
acharya says
i often think we can't get rid of
inequality by educating it well i think
we can get rid of inequality by
educating everyone who wants to be
educated to your point
but don't you think this crazy college
tuition is the reason but or one of the
reasons behind the massive inequality
and you know i i also have heard you
know the data of you know those with the
college education you know make x amount
more and et cetera et cetera but you
know it it's not a causality necessarily
it could be a correlation
and and and so we're we're getting a lot
more people to go into it they're
getting into large amounts of debt debt
that's equivalent to
the down payment for the house on in new
york or california and probably buying a
house outright in a lot of the country
um
do you think and and is maybe that's not
even captured into some of these
inflation numbers
what's your sense of that
i so i think it's it's i think it's
important to separate this the cost of
college is a real problem
but it's often i think misdescribed a
little bit people here you know it costs
i mean you're out in california i'm in
washington you know it costs what
seventy thousand dollars a year to go to
stanford or to go to georgetown or to go
to school like this school school like
that but it's really important to
remember those are not normal schools
and not only that but the schools that
charge that tend to give large amounts
of financial aid to to middle and lower
income people the typical college you
know like a california state university
or the university of maryland baltimore
county
or you name it these places cost vastly
vastly less they still cost a lot and i
think they probably cost too much
but um you can't end up going to one of
those places and end up with with a
hundred with two hundred thousand
dollars worth of debt you know the
average debt for college graduates is
around thirty thousand dollars that's
not nothing um but it's much much less
than the gap so cost is a problem um but
still the truth is that the vast
majority of people who finish
easily pay off their debt not everybody
but the vast majority it's actually a
college yet is a much bigger problem for
dropouts collagen is a bigger problem um
for people who end up with fifteen
thousand dollars of debt but don't get a
degree we don't talk about that crisis
nearly often enough um uh but uh so that
that and then the only other thing i'd
say is there's been some really good
academic studies that have studied
people right at the threshold of getting
into the the the least selective
four-year college in a state like
florida um and the people who are just
above that threshold and who just get
into the least selective four-year
college and thus have a shot to go to
four-year school actually end up doing
substantially better in life over their
20s that's just as far as the data has
gone out than people who just missed
that threshold and so while clearly part
of the value of college is correlation i
do think part of it is also causality
yeah no that last study sounds really
interesting and look you know i i i can
personally testify i went to one of
those schools that i didn't think i
could afford but because the msrp price
was very high uh but i was able to go
even though my my mother made 16 000 a
year in you know 1993. so um i i can
completely vouch for that but anyway i
interrupted the various levers so we
talked about
globalization technology and and
education what let's keep going yeah
yeah so i think you can combine
immigration and trade policy um i think
sometimes people overstate the
importance of trade policy it's not like
you know the trade deals we've signed
have caused all these problems
but some of them really have contributed
to it and basically what we've done is
we have allowed our both immigration and
our trade policy to create much more
competition in the middle and the bottom
of the labor market than at the top so
um as you probably know it's like
impossible if you're a doctor from
another country to move to this country
and become a doctor right you kind of
have to start all over at the beginning
that's basically a big trade barrier
that protects doctors in this country
right it's not we say it's because we
don't trust those other medical systems
but there are plenty of easy ways to
figure out whether doctors are actually
qualified without simply rejecting all
these qualifications from other
countries but we don't do that right we
make it really hard to become a doctor
in this country um on the other hand
we've had this absolute surge of lower
skilled and medium skilled immigration
into this country over the last 30 years
that's had some big benefits but it also
really has created additional
competition and so when you look at our
trade and our immigration policies many
of them really it makes sense that they
have put more pressure on the wages of
people in the middle and the bottom than
at the top and then i will just very
briefly add to that our tax policy
taxes on the very rich have plummeted
the estate tax income taxes corporate
taxes every tax that the very rich pay
have basically plummeted over the last
40 years
and taxes for people in the middle at
the bot and at the bottom which very
important there tend to be the payroll
tax and sales taxes have just not fallen
very much and so over the same period
that the market has caused inequality to
rise our tax code has exacerbated those
changes
rather than flushing
if we could bring up that that animation
from david's twitter account on on how
tax has changed over time i think that
really hits the point home of what
david's just mentioning
there's a an animation that i really
enjoyed and i actually made a video with
it yeah here we go and what you see
actually you could explain this what's
going on it keeps repeating itself so
this is your total tax rate you combine
federal state and local um for the very
richest
families i can't remember you may see it
on there is it the top 0.01 percent and
you know it's something at the very very
top and what you're saying is that the
top the right side is like the the right
data point is for the richest yes thank
you sorry this is the whole tax exactly
right south this is the whole strip this
is the whole tax um this is the whole
country right and so what you can see is
in the middle and the bottom these tax
rates aren't changing very much they're
staying within a fairly narrow range um
that's the yellow line in the middle and
to the left but to the very right where
you're seeing the very very richest
folks the tax rate is plummeting over
time and i want to emphasize this is
actual tax rate this isn't the statutory
tax rate you pay on the last dollar this
is you take someone's total income you
then take all the taxes they pay federal
state and local and back in the 1950s
the very very wealthy were paying more
than half of all of their income in
taxes maybe that's too high may well
have been too high
but it's plummeted to the point where
our tax code now looks extremely flat um
there are fights among economists about
is it totally flat do the rich still pay
somewhat more but the data all points in
the same direction which is it's become
much much flatter than it used to be
over time because we've cut taxes on
stocks on um on other investments on
inheritances uh and on very top incomes
and we haven't done that to sales taxes
and payroll taxes
and and just just make sure people
understand you know each if you look at
the horizontal axis the left is uh the
lowest income earners and then you go to
the 30th percentile 50th 70th 90th 99th
and then 99.99
and then the top 400 people and then the
vertical axis is the tax rate effective
traction to your point it's it's the
total amount they paid i guess divided
by uh their their income and to your
point you see how this flows from 1950
all the way to close to present times
and
yeah the zero to the 90 90th percentile
or so it's been pretty much the same tax
rate give or take while it's really that
top 400 or the 99.99 or even the 99th
percentile that's come down a good bit
and you know where it ends is
fascinating because when it ends in 2018
where the total effective tax rate for
that that top 400 is lower than the
99.99
which is lower than the the group right
before it so how does that happen
because you know when i fill out my
taxes i see you know for every
incremental more you make they're taxing
it a higher amount so how is it possible
that the top 400 are are tax lower than
the 99.99 percentile
you may remember a number of years ago
warren buffett got a bunch of attention
by saying that he paid a lower tax rate
than his secretary um and warren buffett
is very good at at explaining things
pithily um and and in some ways that's
what he's describing what you see here
one of the reasons is that we tax
investments at a lower rate um we've
decided um or or the people selling
policy have decided that if you tax
investments at a lower rate you'll get
much more investment that'll benefit
everyone long term hasn't quite worked
out the way it's been sold but that's
the theory um and so basically we tax um
things like stock returns at a lower
rate than we tax labor income and the
people on the far right of this chart uh
have much more of their income in uh in
capital investments in stocks than they
do uh relative to the to the people in
the middle
yeah and actually i asked that last
question somewhat naively my last career
i was a hedge fund analyst and i
remember i mean my boss who's a
portfolio manager and was the partner uh
he he felt guilty about it he's a great
guy he actually would donate you know we
once made a good investment on an egg
company and he felt so bad because he's
a vegetarian that he donated all of his
profits to uh for humane treatment of
chickens uh but he felt guilty when you
know i learned about this you know i i
was paying a higher tax rate as an
analyst because i that was just income
versus what he was paying because he had
a his income was classified as capital
gains income uh so he was paying roughly
15 while i was paying you know uh 40 or
50 percent uh so so it it it is a it is
a fascinating um phenomenon so we have a
ton of questions here we're already at
our normal
end time but i want to make sure we get
to some questions let me know david if
you've got a run or if you're running
into another uh session but you know one
question that's been coming up a lot um
even before kovid
you know maya sharma from youtube asks
you know do you think universal basic
income is a valid solution in the long
term
so i mean look this is a matter for this
is a great matter for debate right and
and if we have any high school debaters
uh listening today i know that universal
basic income was one of the big topics
that was debated on the high school
circuit last year and and um it seems
like it actually led to a lot of debates
that people really liked because there
are very good philosophical um arguments
on both sides of it what i would say is
um i think that it really does have some
of the same incentive problems um that
we talked about with some of the issues
of societies that tried to get rid of
inequality i know universal basic income
isn't trying to get rid of inequality
but i think when you look at what really
really matters to people
what
correlates with good health what
correlates with happiness it often does
involve work it involves
the dignity that work brings it involves
feeling like you're part of something
larger a larger product a larger project
and so i have some real skepticism about
universal basic income as our solution
and i would be much more interested in a
a set of solutions where we really tried
to substantially increase the returns to
what are now low wage work you can do
that through a much higher minimum wage
you can do it through a much bigger
earned income tax credit and and then
maybe also looked at the idea of
rewarding people more for what are now
unpaid forms of labor like child care
and elder care but to me the idea of a
universal basic income where we're
paying people not to work despite
everything we know about some of the
health and
psychological costs to not working
and in addition
sal i don't think i need to receive
universal basic income you know i have a
job as a journalist and it pays me
enough to live on and i really don't
think our government should be sending
me a check every month uh and you know
there are millions of people who also
don't need to be getting a check every
month so i'm a skeptic of universal
basic income but i also see the
arguments for it and i think um
i think it's it's a good thing that we
as a society have started to debate it
more
yeah and i think the argument would be
you know if we receive checks we'll also
on the other side be taxed higher so
it'd kind of be a wash but it's easier
to implement universal but you know
things like other social safety nets
created some of that disincentive that
you talked about while universal risk
income you can still have a job but yeah
it's an interesting debate you know one
of the things you brought up was minimum
wage and the economic there's an there's
kind of an economic purist would have an
argument against it saying hey if you
artificially raise the market clearing
wage
then
companies you know your classic
economics with their supply and demand
curve you're now going to create this
deadweight loss where
you're not going to hire everyone
there's also arguments that it could
create incentives to move even faster
towards
technology or globalization what are
your counter-arguments to those
arguments
i mean i think there's both a
philosophical and an empirical um
counter argument there's been a real
flowering of research in the minimum
wage over the last 20 to 30 years
and um some of it shows that there there
is a trade-off that if you put in place
a minimum wage you lose some jobs um the
bulk of it shows that the number of jobs
you lose from increasing the minimum
wage within reason if we went to a 50 an
hour minimum wage who knows what would
happen we presumably lose a lot more
jobs the losses are actually
much more modest and that um people it's
not so the small relatively small dollar
changes don't immediately lead to
declines in employment there's a famous
study looking at new jersey and
pennsylvania when one increased their
minimum wage and the other didn't and so
in terms of a perfect economic
laboratory you'd imagine that a whole
bunch of jobs on one side of the border
would move to the other but they didn't
um and so it turns out that people make
decisions for all kinds of complicated
reasons
and the minimum wage often for a
business doesn't lead to some radical
reduction in employment and it can lead
quite quickly to big changes in the
quality of life of people who are
receiving a 20 increase you know five
dollars an hour to six dollars an hour
it's a 20 increase in in pay and so i
think if you kind of look empirically at
the research it suggests that minimum
wage increases have done more good than
harm most of the time and i think
philosophically i understand why a
society might say look we're a wealthy
society we're simply not willing to have
people living below a certain um
standard and so we're gonna set a
minimum standard
and what you know we going back to
either in minimum wage or even this
notion of universal basic income it does
feel like the coveted crisis obviously
for you know no fault of their own many
millions of people are losing their jobs
right now restaurants are
either temporarily or permanently shut
down airlines hotels we can make a long
long list
to some degree some of what the stimulus
package has done
is starting to look a little bit like
universal basic income uh you know
everyone gets a sixteen hundred dollar
check um
every you know uh unemployment insurance
is extended even if you're a contractor
so do you think we're going to naturally
evolve there if this coveted crisis
we have 30 million unemployed
you know 35 million unemployed you know
we
people need to be fed people need to
just be able to pay the rent
uh i would be surprised if this leads us
to universal basic income because um
sending checks to people is extremely
expensive right the math it's just the
way the math is you're sending them to
everyone right and they're not that
small
um and look we're still going to need to
collect the data on this but my instinct
is that these checks being sent to
everyone are not particularly efficient
forms of stimulus they are not a very
good bang for the buck way to keep the
economy functioning and i think there's
a logical way to think through this so
many many people most people have not
lost their jobs
not only have they not lost their jobs
many of them have had their typical
daily or weekly expenses plummet right
they're not paying for gas anymore
they're not paying for the bus they're
not paying for subways um i don't know
about you but the amount of money i
spend on food has plummeted because
instead of picking up a two dollar
coffee or a six dollar sandwich i'm
making myself um peanut butter uh on
bread for lunch because i'm around my
refrigerator um and so these people who
have kept their jobs and had their
expenses go down
millions of them have just gotten these
checks and i think the evidence is
showing that they're not actually going
to spend that money they're going to
save it
yet now you take someone who did lose
her job um
for that person the amount of money that
we are sending them isn't nearly
sufficient to cover the rent to cover
food um to to pay for child care and so
we've got this slightly funny situation
in which we've spent huge amounts of
money spent sending twelve hundred
dollars to everybody below a certain
income threshold for many people that's
more than they need and for other people
it's not nearly enough and yet it's so
expensive that if we wanted to keep
doing it in perpetuity we'd have to to
do massive cuts to other social programs
like medicare and medicaid and so i'd be
surprised if it's where we end up long
term but um lots of surprising things
happen
and what would you you know if you were
emperor uh and you were going through
this situation
what would be your course of action you
know i've heard we had ray dalio on here
and i even chatted with him a little bit
afterwards and he's like you know by
spending trillions and just pumping into
the economy yeah this is increasing the
debt by trillions but the alternative is
worse uh that we go into a depression if
we don't do that uh so so would would
you be in favor of that type of thing
and if you if so like what is the metric
is it by writing these checks to
everyone which it sounds like it
wouldn't be is it you know these kind of
loan programs which seem to have been
misused a little bit by certain
corporations so
how would you try to tackle this
austin goolsbee who's an economist at
the university of chicago um has this
nice kind of series of lessons that he
put on twitter very quick on about virus
economics and i'm going to mistake it
slightly i apologize to austin but the
first rule of virus economics is the
only way to help the economy is to
defeat the virus
and i think that's exactly right so i
think
that we can't get back to normal if
people are still feeling fearing for
their lives if they're feeling fearing
particularly for their parents and their
grandparents lives um it just won't
happen and so i think the the most
effective forms of economic stimulus are
likely to be something like a massive
program to increase testing capacity all
the estimates i've seen say that while
the united states is doing more testing
we're not doing nearly enough
a big program to increase quarantining a
big program to increase
protective equipment for medical workers
a big program to increase contact
tracing
and of course more research into
vaccines and treatments the good news is
while that stuff's really expensive it
pales in comparison to the kind of
trillions of dollars that congress has
spent to try to prop up the economy so i
think if you can think of the economic
stuff as being necessary but really just
being a prop that tries to get us
through a period where we are investing
enormous amounts in
crushing the curve and then allowing us
to begin to operate and also get a
vaccine that strikes me as probably the
most effective approach but it doesn't
really seem to be the approach that
we're following as a society instead
we've got the scatter shot approach in
which we're shoveling massive amounts of
money out the door which i do think is
probably necessary even if it's being
done in some inefficient ways um and
we're not really committing ourselves to
to a huge national project to increase
testing and we're now starting to open
up even though we haven't hit many of
the benchmarks that epidemiologists
say we should hit and so i'd love to be
proven too pessimistic about this and
there really is uncertainty but i feel
like the most likely scenario is that
we're opening up too soon and we are
going to pay a price both in terms of
further outbreaks but also in terms of
our economy sliding back
uh into some kind of lockdown and
further recession when the outbreaks
come
yeah your point is no matter how much
stimulus you put in if people are still
afraid to go outside afraid to to
participate in the economy you know the
stimulus will kind of be just like
pushing on a pushing on a string uh and
i'll i'll add one area for for anybody
listening who's looking to spend a few
billion here there uh i think internet
access for everyone especially in this
time is a very very good investment i
think it would pay many economic
dividends and if you look at it compared
to you know i've done back of the
envelope calculations i think you could
get
all the families who don't have access
today some kind of you know basic
internet that you can use khan academy
on uh for on the order of a few tens of
billions which sounds like a large
number but that's about
point that's about one percent of the
amount of money that's been spent in the
stimulus packages just over the past few
few months and to loot back to the main
topic i mean where is broadband access a
problem it's much more problem among
lower income people than upper income
people
yeah one one question that this is
coming uh from um you know it's going
back to one of your other levels on the
education i i do want to ask this
because it's a thought experiment that
i've had with friends you know just
thinking about the issue jenny scoble
from facebook asks but let's say
everyone gets a college education will
there really be jobs for all of those
people i mean you could imagine what if
everyone had a phd tomorrow
will there really be that many jobs for
for those for those folks
so i love this question i get the
version this question a lot when i'm out
speaking i would actually ask people to
flip it and go not forwards in time but
backwards in time why is it necessary
that everyone gets a high school
education why is it necessary that
everyone gets an 8th grade education why
did we as a society decide that 13 years
of public education was essentially the
minimum that all people should have and
that's not just a hypothetical question
there was a real live debate in this
country in the early 20th century and
around the world about this and there
were people who said come on let's be
realistic
most americans don't need to go to
um high school they need to learn to
read and that's about it we the high
school should be for for the the top
echelons of society it's a waste of time
and money to send ordinary workers to
high school and then there were people
the high school movement which
was a national movement a sort of
national local movement maybe strongest
at first in iowa who said no no no
education will pay off if we create more
educated workers more educated citizens
our society will be healthier and there
will end up being jobs for for many of
those people and that second group
really won the bet in a route
europe for a long time kept education um
high school education is more of an
elite thing we went to mass high school
education and it built so many um great
american industries um it built
agriculture to have educated farmers it
built hollywood
it built american manufacturing it built
one industry after another and so if 13
years was the amount of mass education
that made sense in the early and mid
20th century
why is it that we think that number
wouldn't have gone up almost 100 years
later and i think clearly when you think
about how much more advanced technology
is that number
has gone up and so thinking about 15 or
17 years as the right number for mass
education makes sense and my instinct is
is if we got there much has happened 100
years ago we would find all kinds of
jobs we didn't even know existed for our
more educated citizenry and i don't
think there's a natural limit that says
well nine wasn't enough education 13
years was was enough education but
anything more than 13 would end up being
wasted
yup no and obviously you're preaching to
the choir with when you're talking to me
about the way i think about it is
there is some logic to the argument that
jenny is making that you know a degree
doesn't automatically convert into a job
but from a societal scale the and it's
you know we use years as a proxy and we
use high school and college as a proxy
but it's really can we get people to
that level of critical thinking can we
get them to that level of skill so they
can leverage the technology around them
leverage you know understand the
complexity of the environments so they
can either plug into jobs that already
exist or will exist at 10 years or even
more interesting so they can create new
jobs they can be entrepreneurs at a
small or a large scale which is a job
creation
engine so it is an interesting you know
i think on the margin that argument
there is some you know if
if you just the piece of paper by itself
isn't going to give you the job it's
that the fact that you've actually um
developed those types of skills and you
know we talked a lot about this labor
pyramid inverting now where we need to
get either people to the top of that
labor pyramid into the knowledge economy
to get those skills or you're just gonna
the inequality is going to keep keep
going
so we're way over time this was a super
i i feel like we should yeah we we
should continue this is part one i'm
just going to commit
[Laughter]
um but thank you so much david this was
a really really stimulating conversation
a conversation that i think people need
to be having more and be having in kind
of a you know not politicizing it just
like what are the facts what do we
understand what works what doesn't and
nothing is all bad or all good but we
should all be informed so thank you so
much for for participating thanks for
having me and thanks to all the
the viewers for the great questions
great thanks so much david well thanks
everyone for for watching obviously uh
these conversations go long go longer
when we're really having a good time but
thank you for all of your questions it's
a really important conversation and i uh
look thanks for joining the live stream
and i look forward to seeing all of you
tomorrow
you